olá boa tarde meu nome é
Daniel sou estudante de psicologia e
tenho 21 anos neste momento
então o que eu quero que você imagine é que
a quantidade de vezes que eu ouvi
você é tão jovem e  você vai falar
sobre solidão o que há com isso e o
que eu quero que você entenda ao longo de
toda a apresentação é que ela
ocorre em quase todas as fases da sua vida
e eu vou falar um pouco mais sobre isso
ao longo da apresentação então
sem mais delongas vamos começar com
um pouco de história pessoal então
este sou eu qual é sim é
o da esquerda a propósito com os
dentes estranhos então quando eu era jovem eu realmente
me envolvia em qualquer tipo de atividade ok  Eu
fui no carnaval com minha irmã e a
família que é minha irmã pelo jeito eu
sei que ela está lá então me desculpe eu fui
eu brinquei com muitos amigos eu tinha
um grupo de amigos na minha escola e
principalmente eu tinha um  grupo de amigos na minha
aula de natação eu era um
nadador competitivo  mer durante a maior parte da minha infância,
mas em um ponto eu fui, me
machuquei muito nos dois ombros e
tive que parar de nadar e, obviamente,
sem nadar, meu grupo de amigos no
grupo de natação não permaneceu
meu amigo por muito tempo.  período de
tempo então eu só fui para a escola a propósito
na nova escola eu fui para o ensino médio e
eu realmente não me envolvi muito com
as pessoas na minha escola eu também
não me envolvi com ninguém
fora da minha casa então  Eu só fiquei em
casa jogando videogames comecei a
jogar muitos videogames quase
ficando viciado se eu realmente não me
viciasse e sim por ficar sozinho
por tanto tempo eu acho que meio que desenvolvi a
solidão
se isso pode ser uma condição  então essa foi
basicamente minha experiência com a solidão,
mas o que significa solidão solitária o
que é estar sozinho o que significa
estar sozinho então eu tenho essa citação de
Andrea scope que praticamente diz que o
próprio Bingle é o estado de estar
enquanto solitário  s é um estado de espírito e
isto pode traduzir-se em estar sozinho pode
ser apenas uma consequência de um conjunto momentâneo
de ações enquanto se está sozinho é
esticar esse conjunto de ações por um
longo período de tempo no ponto em que
você simplesmente não consegue ficar feliz com a
quantidade  e a qualidade de suas
interações sociais então eu trouxe um pouco de
exercício nada demais você nem
precisa responder se não quiser mas
eu quero testar seus conhecimentos sobre
solidão ok então estou indo sozinho para o
trabalho você acha  isso é ser solitário
não é claro que não você está apenas caminhando para o
trabalho ok então um amigo meu acabou de morrer
eu preciso de um tempo sozinho você acha
que é ser solitário
não isso é luto ok muito bem eu tenho um
dia de folga do trabalho eu vou  ficar em casa
jogando xbox você acha que é ser
solitário não essa é a minha segunda-feira ok então eu
fui em uma festa cheia de pessoas que me senti
como se eu estivesse sozinho mesmo enquanto conversava com
pessoas que eu conhecia você acha que é
ser solitário sim se você não pode ficar
feliz com  com a qualidade e a quantidade
de suas interações sociais que permanecem
solitárias Eu odeio ficar em casa, mas não posso
ficar feliz lá fora, apenas me sinto
sozinha onde quer que não, isso não é claro,
isso é solitário, então por que
sentimos que precisamos de interações sociais na maior parte do tempo
o tempo bem meu palpite evolução e
eu tenho que agradecer ao sr.  Darwin para isso
porque bem ele foi o primeiro a dizer
que nós viemos dos primatas e
dos macacos se você pode chamar isso e eu
vou dar um péssimo exemplo ok
não me cite sobre isso mas imagine
Tarzan ok
então  Tarzan era um bebê e ainda assim os
primatas sentiam que ele precisava de alguma
proteção ele ele eles sentiam que ele
precisava para viver em sua sociedade
de forma a continuar vivendo se eu posso
dizer isso para isso o que isso pode
nos dizer é primatas  na maioria das vezes
formaria sociedades e grupos de forma
a se defenderem de predadores ou
até mesmo coletar comida de uma forma mais fácil mas
isso era história
ok você acha que eventos sociais ou
solidão é algo que nós
faríamos isso hoje em dia você acha  acho
que você acha que é algo que
ocorre hoje em dia sim sim claro
e eu trouxe alguns exemplos por exemplo
o filme da Pixar é sobre um velho
que perdeu a esposa e apenas sentiu que
precisava fazer algo não é ficar
sozinho  em casa, um original da Netflix chamado
Bojack horseman que basicamente
fala sobre um cavalo que era um
ator infantil e perdeu o emprego,
então ele começou a beber e usar drogas
para evitar ficar sozinho e, finalmente, uma
música horrível de Celine Dion
sozinha.  música muito ruim, mas é
relevante ok, então eu estou bem, lembre-se do que
eu disse que basicamente passamos por
solidão ao longo de toda a nossa vida
sim, eu trouxe três exemplos para você, vou
começar com a solidão na juventude ok,
então entre 90 a 50 e hoje em dia
há uma grande mudança
, não sei se você sabe disso, mas a
depressão maior aumentou cerca de cinco a
oito por cento nos jovens e as crianças
entre as idades de 15 e 24 anos têm uma
taxa de suicídio que é o dobro do
que era no  anos 50, o que é ainda mais assustador é
que a taxa de suicídio de crianças
antes dos 15 anos foi quatro vezes maior do
que nos anos 50, o que eu penso
sobre isso é que a maioria das crianças simplesmente não
brinca fora hoje em dia, elas apenas
desenvolvem esse tipo  de conforto em ficar em
casa jogando ou assistindo TV ou
qualquer outra coisa e isso na maioria das vezes pode
levar à solidão que está diretamente
relacionada à depressão
ok agora solidão nas construções a maioria
de vocês são adultos aqui, então
vou falar diretamente em  você neste momento
há um grande foco nas carreiras há
um enorme clima competitivo entre as
pessoas entre os adultos e na maioria das
vezes as pessoas preferem ficar fazendo
horas extras por exemplo ir
tomar uma bebida com um amigo
por exemplo o aumento do divórcio
taxas isso é um pouco exagerado, mas
imagine a situação ok você acabou de se
divorciar de sua esposa ou marido
e você acha que vai
ficar com o mesmo grupo de amigos
que tinha antes ou o grupo de
amigos vai  dividido
entre vocês dois porque meu palpite é que
vai dividir também de novo a quantidade de
atividades internas vai
influenciar no fato de você
ficar em casa por l  mais e você pode
desenvolver a solidão de ficar sozinho
no grande período de tempo por
último solidão no outro há
cerca de 10 milhões de pessoas neste momento em
Portugal e 2 milhões dessas têm
mais de 65 anos se qualificando
para o grupo mais velho 60% dessas  dois
milhões de pessoas vivem sozinhas sem nenhum
outro idoso sem nenhum outro adulto sem
membros da família e isso tem um
impacto enorme em seu psicológico a
saúde mental simplesmente não pode suportar um período tão longo
sem interações sociais
e é principalmente por isso que o grupo de idosos
acima de 65 anos  tem a maior taxa de
suicídios registrada em todo o
ciclo de vida entre as pessoas ok então agora
esta é uma atividade real não como a
anterior eu vou pedir a vocês para
fecharem os olhos todos por favor
fechem os olhos e levantem a mão se
você já se sentiu sozinho em qualquer
ponto da sua vida ok eu quero ver
essas mãos levantadas por favor não tenha medo de
fazê-lo ok agora sem ir com as
mãos abaixadas eu quero  você abra seus olhos
e olhe em volta ok então meu palpite é que você
concorda comigo quando eu digo que em um
ponto da sua vida você vai ficar
você vai se sentir sozinho então o que eu
pediria para você fazer é imaginar  por
que você o que está te impedindo
de ir para outro ser humano e
apenas dizer oh você está sozinho sentado
aí posso eu posso te fazer companhia eu
também estou aqui o que está te impedindo de
fazer isso porque eu realmente não  não sei
além do constrangimento de ir e
se apresentar a alguém eu realmente
não vejo problema em apresentar isso
a alguém quando eu fui para o ensino médio eu
realmente não tinha certeza de que as pessoas sabiam
quem eu era e acho que era um
dos maiores problemas por que eu me sentia tão
sozinho, então quando eu fui para a universidade
eu me certifiquei de que todo mundo que eu encontrasse
no corredor ou no refeitório ou
no café ou o que quer que eu fosse
lá estendesse minha mão e dissesse ei, eu  m
eles sabem como você está em nossos dias eu posso
encarar os fatos  em eu estava muito sozinho
eu era ruim mas melhorou porque eu me
certifiquei de que melhorou se você é um diretor
ou um líder em seu ambiente de trabalho o
que está impedindo você de reunir alguns
de seus funcionários e apenas sair vamos
sair pelo menos uma ou duas vezes  um mês
vamos jantar vamos almoçar dividimos
a conta e acabamos de nos
conhecer bem está a impedir-te de fazer
isso temos um ditado muito conhecido
aqui em Portugal que é assim e
não te preocupes não em não  -falantes de inglês
eu vou traduzi-lo eles apenas venham
ser um adulto sem perguntas, então isso se
traduz aproximadamente em nós deveríamos nos encontrar algum dia
e nós nunca chegarmos a mim me desculpe, estou
apenas dizendo que é tipo, abençoe
você, você não é  realmente vou abençoá-lo,
então por que estamos apenas dizendo coisas, mas não as
fazendo, esse é o ponto principal
que quero transmitir aqui é por
que não mudamos nosso comportamento no
sentido de não nos sentirmos tão solitários,
mas também fazer os outros se sentirem  menos solitário
ok  obrigado você